[Music]
foreign
growing and aging populations are
shaping our Healthcare Systems which
need to be more effective and smarter
powerful tools such as artificial
intelligence and data science can bring
answers to this Challenge and this
digital strategy is at the heart of the
European health data space launched in
May 2022 to develop safe exchanges of
patients data to deliver better care
Empower search and help EU member states
in their policy making
but what kind of data are we talking
about
it's the information related to our
health that's generated when we see a
doctor or go to hospital this is known
as the primary use of Health Data
the secondary use is the processing of
aggregated Health Data to improve health
care services the development of
medicines and research
Paris hosts one of the most advanced
Health digital infrastructures in Europe
the Health Data Hub links different
actors within the health ecosystem and
has set up a technological platform that
enables public interest projects to
exploit large data sources
artificial intelligence means being able
to move from Healthcare that tree
are already ill
the healthcare that alerts you to the
risk of hospitalization it means moving
from Healthcare that treats to
healthcare that prevents
when it comes to Bringing together
Health Data from different countries
that use different standards and
languages the challenge is to find a
common code this involves two main steps
the first step is to have a common data
model the second step is to set up a
common vocabulary that's a bit like the
construction of a sentence all countries
need to agree on whether to use a
subject verb object construction for
example or subject object verb
pipelines to connect Health databases
are at the heart of the European health
data space but sharing confidential data
requires high levels of security
the French data Hub applies strict
standards of I.T protection to prevent
access to patients personal data
at no point do we have the right to
access directly identifying data we open
secure bubbles for each research project
that operates on our platform these are
bubbles that are totally sealed off from
each other in which researchers have
access only to the pseudonymous data
they need obviously there is no way to
take the data outside of this bubble
Finland is another successful case study
for health data management it runs Finn
data the data Authority for the Social
and Healthcare sector
the agency gives guidance on the
secondary use of Health Data and ensures
that data used for public interest
projects is fully protected
in research but also in teaching in
development and Innovation activities
policy making and so on we have one
contact point in Finland where you can
ask about the quality of the data about
the availability of the price or all
kinds of things you need to know when
you are planning your research
a major step towards the European health
data space will be taken next September
with the launch of its pilot version it
will monitor the transnational use of
Health Data on specific issues such as
cancer rare diseases and health pathways
[Music]